Welcome to The Deep Dive, the
show where we really tried to
distill stacks of articles,
research all sorts of notes into
the most important Nuggets for
you, our listener.
Taking the complex and making
it, well, digestible.
Exactly.
And today, we're plunging into
something that really shapes how
we see the world, often in ways
we don't even realize.
It's about how we consume news
of conflict.
I mean, think about your own
routine.
How do you get updates on, say,
global hotspots?
Is it the traditional TV news?
Probably less and less for many.
People, right?
Or is it something more
immediate, more visceral, maybe
more raw, like a short video
clip popping up on your phone?
Yeah, or a really striking
image, something shared on
social media that just sticks
with you, gets that emotional
reaction.
Precisely.
And that shift leads us to this
really central and honestly
quite unsettling idea that our
sources are unpacking for us
today, which is that Modern
Warfare, it isn't just fought
with bombs and bullets anymore.
It's also waged with cameras,
with live streams, with, well,
expertly curated images.
A second front, almost an
information front.
Exactly.
We're talking about a profound
transformation here, an
evolution of what used to be
called, very discreetly, human,
human intelligence.
Right, the old spy stuff.
Into something our sources are
calling, quite provocatively,
human, human entertainment.
Human.
That's yeah, that hits
differently.
It's not just a clever word
play, is it?
Not at all, according to the
sources.
They argue it represents A
fundamental change in how
conflict is presented and maybe
more importantly, how it's
perceived across the globe.
And what's really fascinating,
or maybe disturbing depending on
how you look at it, is how this
redefinition changes our whole
engagement with conflict.
How so?
Well, think about human the
original kind.
It was always in the shadows,
wasn't it?
The domain of, you know, the
field operative.
Maybe the classic spy in a
trench coat meeting an informant
in secret.
Cultivating sources over months,
years even.
Right where the analysts locked
away somewhere, pouring over
classified files, trying to
piece things together.
It was intelligence for a very
small, specific group.
Generals.
Policymakers.
Exactly.
People making decisions behind
closed doors.
It was meant to be discreet,
controlled, definitely not for
public consumption.
OK, so that's the baseline human
secret controlled for the few.
How does that contrast with this
new human?
What makes it so immediate and
in your face?
Oh, the contrast is just stark.
Today's human intelligence, if
you can even call it that, in
the same breath, is
overwhelmingly first person.
Like shot on a phone.
Yeah, often shaky, maybe
pixelated footage from a
smartphone or even a body camera
worn by a soldier, a fighter.
And our sources, they paint
these incredibly vivid pictures,
examples like the crying child,
you know, covered in dust,
pulled from rubble after an
airstrike.
We've all seen those images.
Gut wrenching.
Or the sound, the screams of a
mother under sirens looking for
her family.
Or, you know, a fighter filming
their own actions with a GoPro
on their helmet.
That's a whole different
perspective.
It is, and this stuff doesn't go
into a secret file.
It's uploaded almost instantly.
It hits TikTok X Instagram.
It, just as the sources say,
floods your feed.
Not just the news feed, but your
personal social media.
Exactly.
It's direct, it's often totally
unfiltered, and it's immediate.
The lag time between something
horrific happening and the whole
world seeing it.
It's shrunk to practically
nothing, minutes sometimes and
the.
Speed.
This rawness.
It takes on another dimension,
doesn't it?
Our sources argued.
This new form of intelligence,
this human, it does more than
just inform.
Yeah, it goes way beyond
informing.
It captivates you, it compels
you.
It keeps you scrolling.
It definitely horrifies, no
question about that.
But the sources say it also
entertains.
That feels wrong to say.
It feels deeply uncomfortable.
And that's exactly the point the
sources are making.
This is the core of human the
suffering isn't just witnessed
passively.
It's consumed.
Actively consumed.
Think about that word.
Witnessing implies maybe
presence, maybe helplessness.
Consumption suggests something
different, more detached, maybe
even voyeuristic.
Like clicking on the next video
even though it's awful.
Precisely.
The algorithms push the
emotional stuff, the shocking
stuff, and this constant stream
transforms real human suffering
into a kind of, well, content, a
commodity.
So the horror becomes the hook.
The horror itself becomes the
hook.
It gets those strong reactions,
shock, grief, anger, maybe even
that morbid curiosity.
But those feelings become part
of the experience of consuming
the show.
It's a really profound shift
from intelligence, being purely
informative, to being primarily
engaging, emotionally engaging.
It almost creates this weird
detached relationship with
suffering that's happening far
away.
Empathy gets tangled up with
just watching.
Yeah, a parasocial relation for
distant trauma.
And that brings us to this
unsettling analogy.
The source uses the idea of
That's entertainment.
Like the old Broadway song about
making even heartbreak beautiful
on stage, applying that to war
seems incredibly dark.
It is dark and it's meant to be
provocative.
The source takes that very
framework, making tragedy
captivating, and applies it
directly to places like Gaza.
How does that work in practice?
Well, the raw images, the
suffering, they become the
verses in this grim performance,
right?
You have the crying child, maybe
framed perfectly.
The keening mother.
Her cries echoing against the
ruins.
Then maybe a sweeping drone shot
over flattened buildings, giving
that tragic overview.
OK, and then, the sources argue,
the producer steps in.
You get the swelling violins,
the sad music laid over the
footage, the captions with
poignant messages.
Setting the mood, basically.
Exactly.
It gives it a dramatic structure
and emotional score and
narrative arc.
It makes this genuine human
tragedy more digestible, maybe
more compelling for a global
audience, more consumable, even
if the consumption is driven by
outrage or sadness.
Which leads to that really blunt
statement from our sources.
Horror itself is the show.
War has become theater atrocity
content.
Wow.
What does that even mean for how
we understand conflict?
It means potentially complete
reframing.
If war is theater, if atrocity
is content, then maybe our
primary role shifts from being
informed citizens who might act
to being spectators.
Just watching the drama unfold,
yeah.
Consuming the tragedy as a
narrative, a series of
compelling, awful events.
It forces us to ask, you know,
is our scrolling, our sharing,
our emoji reactions?
Are angry online debates?
Is that just participating in
the show?
Does it blur the line between
real empathy and just a kind of
desensitized entertainment?
That's the uncomfortable
question.
Does our consumption, even if we
mean well, actually help
perpetuate it by making
suffering A valuable commodity
for different actors?
Does the spectacle become more
powerful than the suffering
itself in grabbing attention,
but maybe not in driving real,
decisive action?
So who are the producers of this
theater?
Who's packaging this content?
Our sources introduce this
really interesting, maybe
controversial term, soft Spooks.
Yeah, soft Spooks.
It definitely challenges our
usual assumptions about who's
neutral in a war zone.
We tend to think of journalists,
aid workers, NGO staff, people
with press vests or Red Cross
logos as impartial witnesses,
right?
That's the ideal, isn't it?
The comforting idea that they're
just there to document the
facts, bear witness without any
agenda, be the neutral eyes and
ears for the world.
But our sources are saying no,
not quite.
They call them narrative
operators, effectively soft
Spooks.
That sounds loaded.
It is loaded, but the key
distinction the sources make is
this.
They're not traditional spies
working for, say, the CIA or MI
6.
They're not doing classic
espionage.
So who do they work for?
They work for causes, they're
donors for specific advocacy
campaigns, and crucially, they
work for global public opinion.
Their mission is to influence
hearts and minds.
Exactly to generate awareness.
Get sympathy, Dr. Action
donations, political pressure
for the specific cause or
population they represent.
So their footage, their stories,
while showing real events,
consciously shaped, they apply
an editorial hand.
They choose which stories to
tell, which angles to push,
which images will hit hardest
internationally.
It's not about making things up.
The source is stressed.
Right.
The suffering is real.
The children in the rubble.
The hunger that's not
fabricated.
Absolutely not.
The sources are very clear.
The devastation, the loss, the
terror.
These are undeniable, horrific
truths.
The sauce books aren't and
inventing these, but they're
using that editorial hand, that
calculation.
There's this understanding that
horror to cut through, all the
noise online must be packaged.
Like a documentary filmmaker
choosing shots and music.
That's a good analogy.
The footage is real, but the
presentation is strategic,
designed for maximum emotional
impact.
And the motivations behind this
packaging?
Our sources point to some very
practical reasons.
Yeah, often quite pragmatic.
NGOs need funding, right?
Compelling stories bringing
donations, Media.
Outlets need need clicks and
views.
Emotional content drives
traffic.
Activists need engagement to
mobilize.
Support pressure politicians.
Organize protests.
So in this context, the
suffering becomes both truth and
a tool, a weapon in the
information war.
That's exactly how the sources
frame it.
A dual entity, undeniable
reality, and a powerful
strategic weapon used to
generate empathy, outrage,
action, funding.
And they say everyone plays this
game not.
Just one side.
No.
Israel plays it, Hamas plays it.
Almost every modern actor in
conflict engages in it.
That raw human, this different
actual human experience gets
transformed, edited, scored with
violins, may be pushed out
globally.
The goal isn't just to inform
anymore.
It's to generate feeling.
Because feeling is power.
It moves people.
It moves money.
It shifts opinion in ways cold
facts rarely do.
This idea of war as theater,
it's not entirely brand new, is
it?
Our sources mentioned a
historical example, the Nyira
testimony back in 1990.
Why is that so important here?
Ah yes, Nyira.
It's a crucial historical
marker, a chilling president.
This was just before the 1st
Gulf War.
A young woman, identified only
as Nyira testified before AUS
congressional committee.
She gave this incredibly
emotional, tearful account,
claims she was a Kuwaiti
refugee, saw Iraqi soldiers
taking babies out of incubators
in a hospital and leaving them
to die on the floor.
Oh my God.
Horrifying.
Absolutely horrifying and it was
broadcast everywhere.
President Bush senior cited it.
It was widely accepted, very
powerful and swaying public
opinion towards intervening
against Iraq.
Hugely influential.
But there's a catch.
Wasn't there?
A massive catch.
It came out later.
Now Ira wasn't just some random
refugee, she was the daughter of
the Kuwaiti ambassador to the
US.
Wow.
And her entire testimony
scripted, coached, rehearsed by
a major American PR firm, Hill
and Knowlton, hired by the
Kuwaiti government.
So it was pure theater.
Pure theater, exactly as the
source describes it.
APR stunt designed to evoke
maximum emotion and justify war.
It wasn't organic, it was a
performance.
Our source calls it the
prototype for war as spectacle.
It showed how easily a powerful
emotional narrative, even a fake
one, could shape reality for
millions.
Devastatingly effective, it
proved the power of weaponized
human intelligence for public
consumption.
OK.
So if Nyira was the prototype,
what makes Gaza, according to
these sources, the full Broadway
production?
How is it different?
More advanced?
It builds on that model, but the
key difference is the sheer
scale, the immediacy, the
ubiquity of it all.
Now in Gaza, almost every image,
every video, every testimony.
It serves this dual purpose.
Evidence and advertisement,
Witness and spectacle.
Exactly.
It's proof of the horror, the
human cost, but it's
simultaneously advocacy, a
narrative piece pushing a
specific perspective designed
for mass consumption.
And the source says the razzle
dazzle the.
Editing the music, the camera
angles.
Yeah, that stuff isn't a
distraction from the reality.
It is the product.
It implies this highly
sophisticated construction of
public perception.
The presentation is the message.
And again, it's not just one
side performing this.
Not at all, the sources
stressed.
This is universal and modern
conflict, Israel's counter
narratives, their press
conferences, the videos the IDF
releases of tunnels or weapons
they'd have.
Their own production value.
Absolutely carefully edited,
narrated, pushed out through
official channels, social media.
They have their own narrative
flair.
In a war fought under cameras,
where everything could be
recorded and broadcast
instantly, performance is as
critical as the battle itself.
It's a battle for the story.
Fundamentally, controlling the
narrative is paramount for
everyone involved.
This focus on narrative brings
us to something incredibly harsh
that the sources highlight
famine, specifically famine as a
strategic weapon.
They really pushed back on the
idea that hunger in Gaza is just
an unfortunate accident of war.
Yeah, that's a very direct claim
from the sources.
They stated plainly the hunger
isn't an accident, it's a
deliberate tactic and has a
long, ugly history.
Starvation as a tool of war.
It's ancient.
Medieval sieges surround a city.
Cut off supplies, wait for
starvation and disease to force
surrender.
Think about the blockades in
World War One.
World War 2 designed to cripple
the enemy, break morale, stop
their ability to fight.
It's brutal, but historically
effective.
So applying that to Gaza now,
the sources suggest the
restrictions on aid, fuel
supplies, that's not just
collateral damage, it's actual
doctrine.
Precisely.
The blockade, the limits on
fuel, water aid, the control
over supply lines.
The source presents these not as
incidental outcomes, but as
deliberate doctrine.
With a specific goal.
A clear, strategic, ruthless
goal.
Make resistance unsustainable.
Break civilian morale.
Force Hamas and by extension
Gaza to yield it's pressure.
Immense constant pressure
without necessarily firing a
shot in every instance.
That sounds just incredibly
cool.
What's the underlying logic
there?
The logic, as the source
explains it, is stark.
War isn't about fairness.
It's about leverage.
Famine provides a slow,
relentless leverage.
It creates massive civilian
suffering.
Which then becomes part of the
spectacle, the human we talked
about.
Right.
Those images circle the globe,
increasing pressure, increasing
desperation.
But in the cold calculus of war
strategy, that civilian
suffering becomes a key pressure
point designed to create an
unbearable situation that
compels surrender, perhaps with
less direct military cost or
condemnation than other actions.
And naturally the different
sides frame this suffering
completely differently.
Oh, absolutely.
That's where the narrative war
really heats up.
Israel frames its actions around
security, dismantling Hamas,
rescuing hostages, preventing
aid diversion.
They argue restrictions are
necessary for their safety.
While Hamas uses the suffering.
As a rallying cry to galvanized
support domestically and
internationally to highlight the
humanitarian crisis.
Position themselves as defenders
against depression.
Generate global outrage.
And the civilians are trapped,
starved of food and starved of
agency, pawns in the game.
That's the tragic reality
depicted.
Their suffering serves different
narrative functions for the
warring parties.
This brutal logic, especially
around famine, connects directly
to how our sources discuss mercy
and war.
It's not portrayed as kindness,
is it?
More like a negotiation.
Exactly.
Forget any romantic notions.
The source defines mercy in war
very clinically.
It's not given freely, it's
granted only to the defeated and
only after they completely
surrender.
So mercy is conditional on
strategic defeat.
Entirely conditional.
It's a concession from the
victor, not a right of the
vanquished.
It's about power dynamics, not
compassion.
The sources use that analogy of
the Knights fighting under the
King's eye to illustrate this.
Can you walk us through that?
Yeah, it's a vivid picture.
Imagine 2 Knights battling it
out.
A king watches, thumb poised.
One knight is clearly stronger,
has wounded the other knocked
him down.
The weaker knight is defeated,
right?
The stronger knight stands over
him, sword ready.
Now the King's thumb comes into
play.
If the fallen knight surrender,
throws down his weapon, yields,
the king might turn his thumb
up.
Mercy.
Life spared, maybe.
But if he refuses, if he spits,
tries one last hopeless attack.
If he chooses defiance, even
when beaten, the thumb goes
down.
No mercy.
The end.
That's the consequence of
refusing to surrender when
you're clearly overcome.
And the source is applying this
directly.
Israel is the strong knight
Gaza, Hamas is the defiant 1,
and therefore no mercy is
forthcoming under this logic.
That's the brutal interpretation
presented.
Israel has the power is
dismantling its opponent Gaza.
Hamas chooses defiance.
And according to this framework,
mercy only follows capitulation.
It's not a moral judgement on
the defiance itself, but a
statement about the unchanging
rules of war.
Terms are set by the victor
after resistance ends.
And we see this historically.
The sources mentioned Germany
and Japan in 45.
Absolutely.
Germany.
Japan.
Utterly defeated.
They surrendered
unconditionally.
They didn't negotiate terms.
They accepted them then, and
only then did the rebuilding
start the path back.
The alternative being.
Complete annihilation, fighting
to the very last man.
Which brings us to that other,
darker analogy.
The source uses the Black Knight
from Monty Python.
Tis but a scratch.
Exactly.
Gaza, in this view, keeps
fighting even as limbs are
Hacked Off.
Brave, maybe, but the source
presents it as suicidal if the
aim is survival and rebuilding,
which requires surrender when
facing overwhelming odds.
All of this points towards a
really stark conclusion from the
sources about the world stance
that Gaza has basically been
abandoned.
It's a tough assertion,
challenges a lot of the rhetoric
we hear.
But the force argues yes,
geopolitically Gaza is alone,
despite all the talk, especially
from the Arab world.
No armies, no jets.
No meaningful military
intervention.
Egypt keeps Rafael mostly shut.
Jordan protects its own border.
Gulf states might offer money
for after, but avoid
confrontation now.
What about Iran?
They support Hamas, don't they?
They provide weapons, money,
rhetoric, yes, but the source
frames this as Iran using Gaza
as a pawn in its bigger chess
game with Israel in the West.
Strategic leverage, not selfless
solidarity risking direct war.
So for billions of Muslims, half
a billion Arabs, Gaza is a
slogan, a symbol, but not a
cause worth dying for in a
military sense.
That's the harsh assessment
presented by the source.
A powerful symbol, a deeply felt
grievance, but not translating
into the kind of military action
that would change the balance on
the ground.
And the West, all the protests
we see.
That's framed as a performance
of solidarity, the source says.
The West loves Gaza as a protest
sign, student activism, chanting
free Palestine.
It's seen as performing
solidarity, expressing moral
outrage, but not delivering
pangible military or decisive
political intervention.
So when the chips are down, the
cold reality of power dictates.
The world bets on Israel,
according to the source.
Israel has the tech, the nukes,
the Intel, the global influence.
Gaza has suffering, and
suffering in this real political
calculation is deemed not
enough.
Which leads us to the inevitable
end game.
According to this cruel logic,
our sources describe how do wars
actually end?
Comes back to that simple brutal
rule.
Wars end when one side
surrenders.
Truces are temporary pauses.
A definitive end requires
capitulation.
And applied to the current
situation.
Gaza Hamas hasn't surrendered.
Israel sees no reason to stop.
Until his goals are met, the
world won't truly intervene, so
the source predicts A grim
continuation.
The siege continues.
Bombs fall.
Famine Titans.
Suffering mounts and, crucially,
the cameras keep rolling.
The human cycle continues.
But it's vital to stress, as the
sources do, this isn't
advocating for destruction.
It's presented as just how wars
work.
Absolutely critical
clarification.
It's not endorsing it.
It's a dispassionate analysis of
power dynamics.
The brutal equation is
resistance without the power to
win.
Just prolongs the suffering.
The longer it goes on without
surrender, the more Gaza bleeds.
And empathy.
Global tears.
They don't stop the bombs.
The bombs do not stop for tears.
That's the chilling line from
the source.
Global empathy is real, but it
doesn't change the military
logic on the ground.
Mercy, if it comes, is
contingent on surrender, not
sorrow.
Which brings us right back to
the start, the full circle human
collapses into human suffering
isn't just lived, it's filmed,
broadcast, consumed.
The cycle completes.
Suffering becomes content.
Truth can become secondary to
narrative.
Human pain gets packaged.
It's the final transformation.
Intelligence into entertainment,
Horror into spectacle.
And that final image the sources
leave us with?
It's haunting.
Yeah, the curtain rises
everyday, the violins swell, the
thumb hangs in the air, and the
show goes on.
It paints this picture of
perpetual theater, globally
broadcast with life and death
hanging on cold logic while the
world watches, appalled yet
captivated.
Wow, OK, that was a really
intense deep dive.
We've gone through this
disturbing shift from human to
human, how conflict becomes
spectacle.
We've looked at the narrative
operators, the soft Spooks, the
brutal strategy of famine, the
cold logic of mercy only
following surrender.
It really challenges how you
think about conflict coverage.
Absolutely.
It forces you to look beneath
the surface of the images and
stories.
So for you listening, think
about this next time you're
scrolling or watching the news.
Knowing this context.
War as theater, atrocity as
content.
How does that change how you
process those images?
Yeah, we really encourage you to
engage critically ask what's the
editorial hand here?
What narrative is being built?
Who benefits?
How is this horror packaged?
Is it designed just to make me
feel something or to inform me
toward action?
It's not about being cynical,
right?
It's about being discerning.
It's about not just consuming
suffering passively.
Exactly.
And maybe a final thought to
take away something to Mull
over.
If human pain becomes this
consumable content, this human,
what responsibility do we have
as the audience?
Do we inadvertently keep the
show going by consuming it?
And could our collective
awareness, our refusal to just
be passive spectators, actually
influence the narrative, Maybe
even influence the outcome
instead of just watching the
performance?
It's a complex question,
definitely worth considering.
Keep exploring these dynamics.
Look for the nuances beyond the
spectacle.
Thank you for joining us on this
pretty heavy deep dive.
Until next time, stay curious
and try to stay informed beyond
the headlines.